the Columbia University Alumni medal for
distinguished service is presented to
Larry J Lawrence 1969 school of general
studies 1971 columbia business school
and then another Ivy League school that
100 miles or so east of here and then I
was in the Marine Corps and then I
worked for a while I had to go to a
meeting once a month and get a military
haircut to do it I couldn't really fade
into the background here in Colombia
because the culture at the time was not
short haircuts certainly was a
transformational wonderful experience
for me but I didn't have to perform
nearly as as Hercule an effete is as
some of the other students I counted
them more recently did there was a young
man who had dropped out of high school
lived on the streets of new york as as a
homeless person for a few years and
found his way into the military found
his way to general studies where he was
also with a top honors student I'm on an
advisory committee for the Dean of
general studies and I'm also co-chair of
an advisory committee for the
Entrepreneurship program at the business
school I serve as a co-chair for the
undergraduate campaign council I did
have the pleasure of being a coach here
with with another general studies alumna
the first general studies alumni reunion
so it's become now the first of what's
intended to be a regular annual series
of general studies reunions we're
building up our tradition is I think
when my name is red general studies
contingent was sitting over here on the
steps and there was a very sort of
boisterous applause Larry Lawrence I
felt like the Sun had come out yeah